waste over three million tons are
generated annually in Nigeria it's an
environmental disaster and a health
hazard only 20 to 30 percent of the
waste is collected for recycling and
reuse these teenage girls from Abuja
want to change that police at a easy
louis and Justyna have created an app
that they hope will make a difference in
the way people deal with their garbage
it's called the green world tech app
individuals who download this app on
your phone we hope to make their lives
easier and healthier because people
dispose their wastes on the streets due
to ignorance of adverse effect that's
where me or my team members created this
app to help to link buyers and sellers
to reduce environmental and
environmental pollution and this is how
the app works a form is sent to an
administrator who responds via email the
prospective buyer then goes to pick up
the refuse or instructs the seller where
to deliver the packaged waste
the app is still in the test phase
so far only friends and neighbors can
use it different types of recyclable
waste are rewarded with a system of
credit points credits can be redeemed
for instance for drinking water
I brought petit plastics
that's for plastics and my god for each
plastic is one point that is equivalent
to through ten naira so at least I'm
thirty Stella
loser Teahupoo has founded an NGO where
girls can go after school to improve
their math and technical skills here
they also learn to program the app and
create a business plan for the system
most of the students actually have been
the one who got the the bias because
they actually went online and searched
within a Buju environment to see who and
who uses plastic as a raw material and
so they did it's themselves I didn't
even help them do it
the girls who want to clean up Nigeria's
wastes hope to go public with their app
soon their goal is to sign up at least
2,000 users in the first quarter of 2018